it can come when you
least expect it
you're not gonna believe that it's like
publishers clearinghouse i thought
nobody ever wins those things
i had no idea what this would
develop into or when you most need it
well there was just no money for
anything yes got a winner at last
it can buy you freedom just every day's
a weekend
every day is a saturday for me or make
you
a prisoner i started getting paranoid at
that point
overnight it can change your life they
didn't even know me till now those
people out there
no one knows the highs and lows better
than the winners who became
instant millionaires
money those who don't have it want it
and those who have it want more
there's the old-fashioned way to make
money through hard work
but everyone dreams of instant riches it
can be a game of chance
a test of intelligence or just plain old
good luck
from the lottery to casinos to the
newest rage
television game shows that promise
sudden wealth everybody wants to become
an instant millionaire i buy everyone
houses and then i buy cars
i'd work when i want to invest the money
retire young
run through the streets naked the lure
of the excitement of becoming a
millionaire i think is something that
captures all of us we all have the dream
we all share the dream so this is one
way to chase it
well look at this lot of people who come
to vegas
they're looking for that big win they're
looking for the mega bucks
this time i'm going to win this time i'm
going to be able to buy that thing this
time i'm going to pay my bills
to me if i win something that's a bonus
las vegas a mecca for dreamers
a flashy boulevard of casinos offering
the promise of
untold riches but it's a fantasy land
that usually
takes more than it gives everyone knows
the risks of losing
but sometimes winning can come with a
huge price tag
john tippin found out the hard way when
he dropped a handful of silver dollars
into a mega buck slot machine
that had a prize of almost 12 million
dollars
instantly he was catapulted into the
public eye
and forever into slot machine history
it's never ever been in my mind in
the 20 years that i've been coming here
it's overwhelming
and they don't train you for this kind
of stuff
for john tippin gambling was second
nature
he played games of chance since
childhood growing up as a plowboy in
rural oklahoma
it was often his only entertainment it
doesn't matter on
whether it's 25 cents or 5 or
10 000 on the craft table it's the game
that is exciting to me
coming from a small farming community in
oklahoma
i grew up with my buddies we didn't have
tv or anything playing poker
and we learned at eight years old or
everything and it's always been a part
of my life
by age 50 john had created a good life
for himself
both he and his wife stella had high
level management positions
with the u.s postal service in hawaii as
a labor relations specialist
john earned a comfortable living and
whenever possible
traveled to las vegas nevada to indulge
in his favorite pastime
gambling he loved the risk the thrill of
the game
the chance of the lucky strike before
megabucks
vegas was a outlet for me and stella to
relieve our work stresses
there's always a chance for that big one
and you just can't seem to wait for the
next hand and
and it's a thrill it's just the
anticipation
maybe it's the suspense of probably when
you're gonna get it
in winning jackpots that's
that's what i'm there for
[Music]
in january of 1996 john estella made one
of their
frequent visits to las vegas they played
the high stakes rooms
games like baccarat blackjack and video
poker
they spent little time playing the slot
machines but every trip
there was one slot they'd play the
megabucks
a machine that offered a multi-million
dollar jackpot
megabucks is known as a linked
progressive game
with 745 machines connected throughout
nevada
and a base prize of 7 million dollars
the prize increases with every player
it's the biggest slot machine jackpot in
the world
well out of every dollar that's played
into a machine a few pennies will go
towards the mega jackpot
and that's you see on a meter it grows
on the meter and the progressive jackpot
that's on the machine
is an indication of what you'll win if
you line up the winning symbols
on january 27th 1996
megabucks had reached its all-time high
11.9 million dollars
oh you give me another challenge louis i
got you
all right still groggy from playing
blackjack until sunrise that morning
john ambled onto the casino floor at the
las vegas hilton around midday
looking for his wife this is where
stella was playing this is where i found
her when i came down
in the morning so stella stella always
plays these and when i came down to see
her she had like
400 credits on here already which is a
very good day
400 i sat down beside her
and mine wouldn't give me spit so i only
stayed about a half hour
john made his way through the casino
playing various games
until finally he worked his way to the
mega bucks machines
well every trip i make to vegas
i make it a rule to play at least one
rack which is a hundred dollars
on the megabots just because you're in
vegas that's the thing to do
and at that point the megabucks had
never been that high before
ever so you can't just walk
past it and not at least play one rack
john dropped a handful of coins into the
machine
nine dollars in all and began to play
so i was down to only three credits left
in this machine
and i was sitting here like this looking
back
looking around the floor to see where i
was going to go next and i twisted
one by one the winning eagles lined up
the lights began to flash and the bell
began to ring
and i didn't remember hearing the bells
and whistles go off
the first thing i remember is the people
screaming
and i looked back around and i didn't
even know what i had
john had hit the big one 11 million
968 359 dollars
he'd become the world record slot
machine jackpot winner
for the next 25 years he would receive
an annual check
for almost 500 000
my first conscious thought was not a
good one
because people were already coming
around me and i thought
oh my god my life has just changed
[Music]
whisked away from the excitement on the
casino floor
john was taken to the verona suite at
the top of the hilton
a 15 888 square foot penthouse apartment
so lavish that only the truly super rich
are allowed to stay there
get ready to knock your socks off oh my
it hasn't changed
[Music]
there's room after room full of art and
antiques
[Music]
fifty thousand dollar marble top tables
from italy
treasures from french castles
fireplaces everywhere
[Music]
look at this
wow lol i mean
i i've never seen anything like this i'm
just a plow boy from oklahoma
what am i doing in a place like this
[Applause]
[Music]
thinking that after a few interviews and
photographs he could begin to adjust to
his windfall
john agreed to sign the media release
but
quickly he found the constant media
attention overwhelming
everybody wanted a piece of john tippin
but all
john wanted was to be left alone
my wife thinks i was very calm and that
i was very
rational when i was talking to the media
inside i was just
i was just all turmoil like a tornado
back home in hawaii the pressure
continued
there were endless calls and letters
from around the world asking for money
and help
he couldn't leave his home without being
gawked at followed
and touched for good luck it was just
horrible
and i i started getting paranoid at that
point
i started feeling fearing that someone
would kidnap stella
or me or whatever the last straw came
when someone tried to steal his identity
diverting his mail to an address in
nevada
fear and paranoia took over john
withdrew
from public life i i was just starting
to get terrified
i just wanted to make everything
disappear for almost three and a half
years
john stayed underground careers were
abandoned
friendship slipped away he and stella
fled their small
condo then quietly moved into a new home
on the 21st floor of a tight security
building
and i didn't even take any clothes or
suitcase or piece of furniture
i walked out of my own place and i
haven't been back it's still there
i still own it i think the goldfish
might have died by now
[Music]
finally relief came for john and stella
when a new mega bucks winner
took the title of world record jackpot
holder
after more than a year of celebrity the
attention declined
now they could be the masters of their
own lives
i would say it's about a year ago i
finally decided that
you know all of this is within my
control
i dictate how my life should be
and i decided that i'm tired of all this
dodging and hiding and
and running and i decided
i've learned a lot i've educated myself
i can deal with the media but i do it on
my terms now
today john and stella often return to
what they call their home away from home
las vegas
i will be here for john we'll be here 24
hours a day with butler service
to take care of any john's needs and his
wife's but now
they only travel first class and they're
treated like
royalty now i fly in i'm picked up by
limo
i'm taking the high suite i'm giving all
the show tickets i'm giving everything
and the casinos pay for just about
everything
all the casinos know that i'm going to
be paid for another 25 years
they don't like my business so
i'm treated very well welcome back i'm
glad you're here all right
she's gonna take you up to your room
five years ago i was still that plowboy
from oklahoma
today i realized i'm a millionaire with
clout
and in this town clout clout works i
came to the right place at the right
time
after years of emotional struggling john
is finally at peace with his win
today he's writing a book about his
experiences
a textbook of sorts to guide other big
jackpot winners through the highs and
lows of instant wealth
i think when you come to that adjustment
where you understand that you're not a
bad person
because you're not giving it away to
everybody that's when you i finally
decided that okay i'm at peace with this
now
i'm a good person i'm helping as i can
and and now go forward
though john became an instant
millionaire he didn't become instantly
happy
having huge wealth especially public
wealth
can bring fear responsibility and loss
it did for john tippin but finally
it also brought happiness and peace of
mind
i just decided from now on the roller
coaster is just going high
and i'm in control and i'm ready to have
some fun with it
and i'm ready to share my experiences
that's why i came up
all over the world the lottery offers
the promise of riches
a chance to make dreams come true
everyone has a fantasy of what they do
with the money
doug wood dreamt for years of hitting
the jackpot
so when he won almost 4 million dollars
he knew just what to do with his money
he couldn't give it away
fast enough i used to put myself to
sleep overnight
dreaming that i'd won about nine million
pounds on the lottery and what i would
do with it
which charities i would support and send
money to etc
at age 58 the future looked bleak for
doug wood
laid off from his job as a clerk in a
stockbroker's office
he'd been unemployed for three years and
was living on meager public assistance
his home was a cold drafty run down flat
in a small seaside town outside of
london before i won the lottery life was
an absolute misery
well there was just no money for
anything i think he was a bit despondent
because of his age and he thought
when you get to 50 you're not going to
get anything aren't you at the age of 58
as i was then
i had no chance of getting a job it was
just
a matter of living on social security
benefits
no future
whatsoever
[Music]
but in september of 1995 doug's luck
began to change
first there was the sunday night bingo
game and
i didn't feel particularly lucky
[Music]
but on the very last house of the day
i won one thousand and seven pounds
which if you're unemployed on 44 pounds
is an absolute
fortune thank you
then on thursday a one and a half pound
horse racing bet
paid back fifteen hundred pounds in
five days he'd won a total of two
thousand five hundred forty eight pounds
almost four 000 us dollars it was a
terrific
week it really was flush with extra cash
doug decided to spend more than his
usual three pounds on the lottery
instead he invested five pounds on
lottery tickets
i mean i've got this one thousand pounds
so i got mistakes i could have fooled it
and luckily i did because it was
the fourth line that actually won
it's the 44th national lottery live
on september 16th 1995
doug sat down to watch the saturday
night lottery show on television
the jackpot was equivalent to 33 million
u.s
dollars as the balls dropped doug
watched as the numbers lined up i'm
watching tv
watching the lottery show and i thought
those numbers look familiar i hope it's
not the same as last week
the week before i'd had six numbers
but they were on different lines
so i went and got my ticket out
and checked it off and then they were
all six numbers
i'm thinking christ this is going to
change my life forever
[Music]
doug wood had become an instant
millionaire
that night there were seven other
winners of the 22 million pound prize
doug's share was 2.68 million pounds
almost 4 million us dollars iran
put in my claim and they said we've come
back to you in about an
hour don't tell anybody
fair enough first thing i do is tell my
sister
morning darling kathy tanner doug's
friend of 15 years
and the manager of the booking shop
where he places his horse racing bets
remembers when doug won he came in the
shop on the tuesday his normal self
morning beauty full came up to the
county gave me this piece of paper he
said
have a read of that and i burst into
tests i just
burst into tears he said well
aren't you going to say anything so i
went came from behind the counter went
and i said well give us a hug then i
said well i've never hogged a
millionaire before
he went multi-million now i said no
don't get cocky like
[Music]
that monday doug quietly received his
check for 2.68 million pounds
he rejected the lottery commission's
request to make his win public
while most people relish the fame that
comes with instant wealth
doug wanted no part of the fanfare they
asked me
if i was willing to go public
and i said no i wanted to keep it under
wraps
there was so much media coverage
and hounding of people
and i didn't want any of that
so i said no that was it
just as he dreamed doug began to give
his money away
to family and causes dear to his heart
first there were six figure checks to
his brother and sister
then private donation checks of twenty
five thousand pounds each
to a local mammogram center the
salvation army
and doug's favorite charity the royal
national lifeboat institution
in the first week alone doug gave away
480
000 pounds almost three-quarters of a
million dollars
there are so many charities that i want
to give to
i want to give it to
people that really need it or deserve it
doug's own life began to change as well
first he purchased a small bungalow
close to his rental flash
then he began traveling the world
[Music]
put 200 pounds on natalie jay
at four to one
he also began to visit every horse
racing track in the united kingdom
[Music]
since doug doesn't drive he hired his
good friends mandy yalup and denise
macklin
to take him to the track three or four
times each week
doug gives them betting money and
together they dine in the members only
restaurants
and enjoy a day at the races my ambition
was to see every racecourse in the
country
which i've done as far as england is
concerned
and now i've got two left to do
in the british isles
[Music]
despite doug's philanthropy and
immediate change in lifestyle
he still managed to keep his win a
secret from the media
the local folks suspected something but
they protected their neighbor and friend
when a newspaper offered ten thousand
pounds to anyone who could identify a
lottery winner
no one pointed a finger at doug she
wouldn't do that
it was more the fact that the press
didn't know that he that helped
him keep it as quiet i know he was
pleased with his neighbours
for not blowing the whistle on him not
many people
that couldn't do with 10 grand but nope
they didn't say a word
brilliant neighbours i've got absolutely
brilliant
god does it take three of you a change
of battery
finally it was doug's own generosity
that blew his cover
almost a year after winning the lottery
he made a twenty thousand pound donation
equivalent to thirty five thousand u s
dollars
to a local charity the surf lifesaving
association
when doug forgot to specify that the
donation was private
the group invited the press to come to
the czech presentation
but nobody said anything about the press
being there
so in the next morning when we go down
there
it was every newspaper and his brother
it was total chaos
if i'd known that it was going to be
like that i would have had one of these
big checks made
but i was only there with a check from a
checkbook
almost a year doug had avoided publicity
but now he was comfortable with being a
millionaire
and with the media attention after 10
months i was used to
the good life i'd learned how to handle
myself and my money it it didn't phase
me at all
20 30 40 50.
i moved very very smoothly
from being poor to being extremely rich
[Music]
when doug wood won the lottery it was a
dream come true
becoming a millionaire has allowed him
to fulfill his greatest pleasure
taking care of his friends and family he
sends them on luxury vacations
buys them necessities and best of all
shares the pleasure of their company
yourself
thank you he's just so generous he wants
to share it
i just wouldn't have seen or done an
awful lot of the things
that i have done in the last five years
if it wasn't for doug
meeting doug does sound a bit thing but
it's like winning the lottery
he's made a few dreams come true and i
am so grateful
see i've not only brought pleasure to my
life i brought
pleasure to their lives as well well
sorry about that
i got a winner
[Music]
everybody wants to strike it rich even
father mike berner
a roman catholic priest dreamt of a big
win
often buying lottery tickets and mailing
in sweepstakes forms
but when father burner suddenly found
himself one million dollars richer
he had to think carefully about how to
balance riches
with religion you're surprised as all
get out
when they're there i don't think anybody
actually thinks they're gonna come to
the door to you
i personally thought i would never win
[Music]
father mike berner was content as a
catholic parish priest
in the tiny hamlet of erling iowa his
life was busy
with daily mass lord receive these gifts
and let our offerings make us holy
visits to the elderly for christ did not
enter into a sanctuary made by hands
yes sir um how old were you when you
realized that you wanted to be a priest
and classroom sessions with the local
school children christ was anointed
priest prophetess king well remember
this town's only 400 people
250 registered households we're a small
country parish
it is a unique little cultural hub
[Music]
in keeping with his vocation he led a
simple
no-frills lifestyle committed to his
community
and making ends meet on an annual salary
of just fourteen
thousand dollars thank the good lord for
credit cards because
that's what we lived off of we ran those
up pretty well
like all good red-blooded americans i
had a little debt
[Music]
like many of the locals father burner
often filled in the sweepstakes entry
forms
that came in his mail from publishers
clearinghouse
after all why not i suppose the reason
you play it is you think
in the back of your mind you might
possibly win
for 33 investment it's not a bad return
it's like winning the lottery you know
everybody throws a dollar to buy a
ticket but do you really think you're
going to win
then on a blazing hot day in august of
1998
an unusual event took place in earlying
iowa
the publishers clearinghouse prize
patrol van had cruised into town
and they were looking for father mike
[Music]
i came up to the back parking lot here
and the kids said everybody in town is
looking for you and
i thought someone had died that's
usually when someone's looking for the
priest
and they said oh no the prize patrol's
here and they're looking for you
anticipating cameras and dressed only in
shorts and a t-shirt
father burner quickly changed into his
black suit and collar
as the doorbell rang
father mike i'm pretty quick on my feet
once in a while and i thought i'm not
answering
the door looking like this on national
tv
would you come open the door please good
craving
i think the whole town knew it before he
did because we had quite a
gathering up here just waiting for him
to come you've just won the publisher's
clearing house sweepstakes
congratulations you just won a million
dollars
come in where it's cooler no you step
back for a minute come on step out for a
minute
by the time father burner opened his
front door the entire town had
congregated in front of the rectory
to watch dave sayer head of the prize
patrol
present father burner with a jumbo sized
check for one million dollars
now that takes your breath away they rip
the paper off right there on the porch
and they've got your name
and there's no mistake now it's you
you're the one
why did i win the good lord knows i have
no idea what i won
no idea whatsoever well father burner
knew he was
blessed to begin with and this was just
one more blessing but a mighty one
the following days were a whirlwind
there was an all-expenses-paid trip to
new york city
appearances on david letterman and rosie
o'donnell
and best of all in response to a letter
he'd sent
father berner and a friend were invited
to celebrate mass
at st patrick's cathedral with cardinal
john o'connor
now two priests young priests from
southwest iowa
are never going to go to st pass
cathedral in new york and cotton
celebrate
had i not won publishers clearing house
it has opened a few doors that would
otherwise
never have been opened
[Music]
though father burner won a million
dollars any real changes in his
day-to-day life were modest
his million is paid in installments over
the next 30 years
after an initial payment of fifty
thousand dollars
father burner will receive a yearly
check for 25 000
until a final lump sum of 250
000 is paid just in time for his
retirement
at age 68.
i haven't done anything i bought a new
car but i'm making car payments on i
reduce the credit a little bit
i haven't taken a tour of the world i
haven't gone on vacation
the wardrobe is still basic black every
now and then i see him smoking a cigar
you know a big old cigar and i i think
that's oh you know
to me that was something different that
he's never done before
all in all a fantastic gift but it's not
a million dollars up front
[Music]
with so much media attention focused on
the millionaire parish priest
father burner suddenly found himself
inundated with donation requests
400 letters arrived in the first week
alone
and then they keep coming and coming and
coming and coming and he's like oh my
god i look at all these
requests that people need people need
money he had to do some soul searching
and find out
what what am i going to do with this
money i think the misinterpretation is
that you have a million dollars under
the bed upstairs cash ready to go small
denominations
unmarked series you know please send as
soon as possible but just it's not true
overwhelmed by the requests father
burner finally chose to put most of the
money into an educational trust
for his nieces and nephews the rest is
donated anonymously
to his community and to catholic
charities
the nice thing is that someone wanted
that could really use the money that's
going to take the money and he's going
to put it
to good use sure he's going to benefit
but his family's going to benefit
and a lot of other people are going to
benefit money's money
and there's no u-haul following the
hearse
it's all going to stay on this side
i can't take it with me pray my brothers
and sisters that our sacrifice
this morning may be made acceptable to
god the almighty father
today father burner still lives happily
in earlying performing his parish duties
guiding his students and celebrating
daily mass
having more money hasn't changed his
life materially but it has afforded him
more opportunities to help others
and it's given him the thrill of a
lifetime
i think you're like the smallest
childhood memory of christmas
like when you're about four or five or
six and you get up and at four in the
morning and you run down that tree
it's the most fantastic day of the year
and uh
so you elevate it to adulthood you say
well this probably the most fantastic
day of my life
next to the resurrection i got nothing
to look forward to
they didn't even know me till now those
people out there
she's a skilled professional a good
friend
a caring mom and a hard worker
but when executive secretary deanne
scherning left a secure job to help
start a new company
she had no idea that she would also
become
a millionaire i honestly had no idea of
what
what an impact it would have on me
[Music]
in 1994 deanne scherning was working as
a high level administrative assistant
for a computer graphics company in
california silicon valley
when her boss jim clark left to launch a
new business
deanne decided to take the risk and join
his venture
clark named his company mosaic
communications
later it would become known as netscape
with no guaranteed future and no raise
in pay
the one perk deanne received was 10 000
stock options in the new company
at a cost of just ten dollars
at the time deanne had no idea what a
stock option was
let alone how it would change her life
i just figured that whatever jim did was
going to
turn out great
working long hours and with a long
commute
deanne moved into a mobile home park
right next door to her parents
with both of them in ill health deanne's
free time was spent caring for them
it was extremely stressful and
depending on the day my mom had cancer
and dad had
a congestive heart failure there were
some tough times
you know some days i had to leave early
just to go
because they had called
[Music]
quickly the business grew jim clark
teamed up with university of illinois
computer scientist mark andreessen
and together they created a plan for a
computer program
that made it possible to more easily
navigate the vast internet
andreessen recruited several students
from his university program to write the
code
they named the company netscape with
young students as its primary staff
the fledgling company quickly became
more college dorm
than business office i was constantly
you know sending them emails that
they've got to start cleaning up their
mess
and then i started going out and buying
groceries because i realized that they
were not leaving the office
to go and eat they were not going home
to sleep
i mean i sounded just like their mother
you know getting after them
always a caretaker deanne worked
tirelessly at her job
earning the nickname dorm mom and
finally netscape mom
a moniker that even ended up on her
business card she used to go around and
make sure people paid attention to
things that
people who are living a dorm style life
don't pay attention to right
you know keeping track of people's
showering habits yeah cleanliness
barely a year after diane had joined
clark's new venture
netscape was ready to sell its stock on
the new york stock exchange
when the board of directors announced
that those with founders stock would
have their options doubled
diane now had 20 000 shares of netscape
then netscape had its first day of
trading the stock performed beyond their
wildest expectations
in a matter of hours deanne made almost
1.1 million dollars
over 20 times her annual salary i
figured it was going to be an extremely
exciting day but i had
no idea it was going to be that exciting
while still employed at netscape diane
began selling her stock for cash
she received a total of more than 1.2
million dollars
it was a hefty sum to guarantee her a
secure position for life
then after years of long hours and hard
work
dean decided to retire from netscape
her administrative assistant days were
over
now she was looking ahead to easy street
mom died in october of 95
she couldn't comprehend what was really
going on dad of course
saw this this excitement and was
extremely proud of his daughter very
proud of his daughter
diane moved out of the mobile home park
and bought her dream home in a san jose
hills retirement community
she's learning to golf and even has her
own customized golf cart
but ironically those early days of
retirement
turned out to be her biggest challenge
she knew she wanted to retire
and i mean she had all in her mind it
was all set you know she's going to
live the life of leisure and play golf
and do all this but
what i see in diane is that she really
needs and wants to be with people
and all of a sudden i'm out of all of
that activity
and for the first couple of months it
was fine
but then i started feeling um like i was
kind of away from everything
and and yet i was always busy
i love the hair hair looks great makes
me look younger huh
oh absolutely yeah
so before long diane was back in action
within two years of leaving netscape she
began working part-time at another
startup venture called hopelink
hopelink uses internet technology to
match patients with clinical trials and
treatments
with a parent loss to cancer it's a
cause close to her heart
i wish that we that hope link was here
when mom and dad were here because
maybe their their lives could have been
extended a little bit longer
but there's no diet coke
money must be having a fit at hope link
diane's administrative skills are once
again partnered
with her maternal instincts
you know when coffee does this to a sink
you really wonder what is just your
stomach
even as a millionaire she's still doing
the dishes
still taking care of her kids remember
it's friday
and any food left in here trap is thrown
out
she's got such a joy for life and
enthusiasm and it affects everybody
around her
she's got the kindest heart
of anybody i think i know ryan ryan ryan
[Music]
deanne scherning hasn't changed since
becoming a millionaire
she's still the caretaker still looking
out for everyone else
in fact she's even thrilled that her
story may be helping other secretaries
ask for and receive the financial
rewards
she feels they deserve they are asking
and getting stock options now so
they're calling me the secretary's role
model
which to me is is a huge huge honor
if anyone deserves becoming a
millionaire
i think it's been really do
she deserves it she worked hard for it
[Music]
instant wealth the odds are against it
whether it's the lottery sweepstakes or
casinos
the chances of winning are remote so
when
ian woodley found himself competing with
only six other people to win a million
pounds
he seized the moment and the million to
become
england's first game show millionaire
it's who owned me it's what life is like
playing with pulpers
just common people you see i remember
you never used to
speak like that when you had nothing and
had to borrow it to pay
i've always said you know i just wanted
to um have enough money
not to ever have to worry and not go to
work
oh sorry ian woodley is a regular guy
not one for pretense
laura hey they're alongside us filming
us
all he ever wanted was a simple life to
take care of his children
hang out with his buddies at the snooker
hall and play music with his friends
en is what you see is what you get
ian could no more put on ears and graces
or change the way he is
for the queen herself that is ian i
don't worry about anything i just take
you know
whatever happens happens
at age 37 ian woodley had a business
selling children's clothes in london's
public markets
but that business came to a crashing
halt when his van and all his
merchandise were stolen
with no job prospects one year of
unemployment
turned into two separated from his wife
and with three children to help support
ian needed to find a job
but ian's luck took a dramatic turn when
england's popular tv
show tfi friday offered a chance for
someone
to become a millionaire
competing with the hit game show who
wants to be a millionaire
tfi friday created a new segment called
someone's going to be a millionaire
with that guarantee in mind ian made
numerous phone calls to the show's
hotline
and qualified as one of the lucky
contestants but he seemed to have this
feeling he'd said it a couple of times
i'm gonna win it
before we go to the next ad break one of
these people will become
a millionaire while the odds of winning
the lottery can be one in a million
these odds were only one in seven
ian knew he'd never be closer to
becoming a millionaire
i'm never going to get a chance like to
be standing say with seven people for a
million bits just won't never happen
again
the answer is on christmas eve 1999
ian stood alongside six other
contestants answering questions before a
national audience
one by one the contestants were
eliminated
the questions was just potluck and you
just got one question at a time if you
got it right you stayed in
got it wrong he was out finally
it was down to ian one more correct
answer
and he would become a millionaire in the
last one i'd sort of knew but
i thought it's too easy you know for one
million pounds
what is the answer you know you're
fighting with yourself because like you
know what what's at stake like
if i get that right i won the million
the answer is
ian woodley won the equivalent of one
and a half million
u.s dollars it was the biggest cash
prize in television history
[Music]
ian immediately showed his generosity
first paying off his ex-wife's mortgage
then buying her a new seven-seater car
to transport their three children
there was money for his parents a
vacation weekend for his relatives
and a trip to tenery for 12 of his pals
the only thing ian bought for himself
was a new car
though he'd like to own a nice house
he'd prefer to see his money grow
he's entrusted his fortune to an
investment banker and a portfolio of
stocks and bonds
i think with ian you know
he's doing things right most of it now
is invested
so that later on you know like he and
the kids and things
they'll always be okay that's the main
thing he's got no intention of
of ruining it and splashing all his
money out he's invested
that's his that's his future
[Music]
today ian receives a weekly allowance of
500 pounds
he lives with his girlfriend kate in her
flat visits his parents daily
and spends time with his kids picking
them up from school
and caring for them a few afternoons
each week he always said he just wanted
enough money
to do what he wants not work and play
cards
and just be able to look after his kids
[Music]
at least four nights a week he indulges
his favorite pastime at the kansas city
snooker hall
playing billiards and cards with his
buddies
yeah bit quicker
[Music]
and on occasion even pursues his hobby
as a drummer
jamming with friends at a local
rehearsal studio
well he wants us to get together more
because obviously he's got lots of free
time
it's a bit difficult for us working
friends just every day is a weekend
every day is a saturday for me so i'm
just really lucky you know
[Music]
but winning a million pounds doesn't
come completely free
and easy there are still fears attached
to overnight wealth
for ian it's the worry that people
expect him to be a big spender
to spread his money around to buy them
things
and pay their way now you worry that
people
you know sort of jealous of you or think
less or you know i don't know really or
you worry that
people expect you to do more he still
hates losing he still goes into one when
he loses
but that hasn't stopped ian from
enjoying the simple life he always
wanted
he does as he pleases mostly unchanged
by becoming a millionaire probably my
belly
has got bigger just eating more not
doing nothing
not working he's he's okay he's he's as
good as gold
but he hasn't changed at all
today ian is philosophical about his
windfall
wondering what made him the lucky winner
like when i go football like you look
around there's 20 000 people in the in
the crowd
you think you know it could have been
any one of them sort of thing and that's
just a small thing
and then it's just as lucky as me
[Music]
call it luck fate karma
an act of god or just being in the right
place at the right time
i love you there's no other way to
explain
instant wealth whether it comes as a
total surprise
or after years of betting on the long
shot yes
one thing is certain a million dollars
will change your life forever
it can bring shock joy guilt
even fear and loneliness while every big
winner faces unexpected challenges
they all would agree that becoming an
instant millionaire
is well worth the price of admission if
they need it
and i can supply it they can have it
it's as easy as that put all of your
heart and soul
into it because you will be rewarded
i'd rather be known as a good priest
than a priest with a million dollars
i feel that i'm lucky because i don't
want much
i'm a simple man and life has been good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you